how are you doing how are you
i'm so well obviously happy to be here
and more importantly congrats on the
show it looks incredible
oh thank you so much it is a really
wild ride this surreal time
you know 2020 trying to launch a show
in this has been such an extraordinary
challenge but i'm so grateful for it
i'm so grateful to have the opportunity
and you know it's so funny because
i actually want to ask you life advice
before
anything to do with food like
how do you be so
unafraid with people you know some
people would like call it like
oh you're harsh you're mean you're rude
you i mean you made the idiot sandwich
where you put
two pieces of bread between you know
with a human being in between
and that's just funny um that's just
straight up funny
maybe it's comedy like that helps you
get away with it but i am
someone who really worries about
people's feelings like i am a human
welcome mat i am a human doormat
sometimes i am a human like
is everything and everyone okay and
that's just my journey in life
um but i really watch people
who are so strong brave ballsy and
unapologetic and i wonder what that
journey of life is like because i've
never known it and i don't know if i
ever will
what is it like um
you know first of all i have to tell you
that my wife is tougher than me okay
she is a real nut buster let me tell you
um five amazing kids we've just had our
fifth
uh literally 18 months ago um dealing
with
you know situations in kitchens live and
getting the best out of you know
individuals and push them to the extent
takes courage um commitment stamina
i think more importantly it's an amazing
career to have when you want to
be the very best at it so you know from
kitchen nightmares to 24 hours to hell
and back
dealing with those real life situations
um drew i haven't got
three months to spend with them i'm
spending you know seven to ten days with
them at a time and
i want to give them everything i've got
so that may come across a little bit
blunt
um slightly sort of uh abruptly but
it's straight to the point because if
there's one thing my mum taught me was
get off your chest be honest um and um
yeah just get straight to the heart of
the matter once you've got that
you know opened up you know you then
start dissecting the problem
and dealing with it you know head-on but
there's
i i that's very interesting because i
think i am really honest
and i am direct and i am unafraid i
don't think i would be here if i was
really an actual like spineless doormat
i clearly have the balls and the
confidence to have gotten myself
to where i've gotten to and i met you in
person by the way at
a restaurant one time and i was so
excited because
my kids and i watched master chef junior
and we met you you were the nicest
person
so kind so ingratiating but is there
like it is it
a relief in life to just say what's on
your mind
what is it like i because i think i say
it in a comedic way or in a safe room
but not out in front like i i kind of
really want to be you for a day
or a lot or a year
what's it like it makes the situation in
your day
um a lot clearer because you're not
harboring problems and so if there's one
thing that we all learned not just
through the lockdown
twice um now over the last nine months
which has been pretty horrific for
everybody
it's about getting to the getting to
heart of what's wrong and so when i walk
into the kitchen
tonight for instance you know rational
ramsay just celebrated
22 years in chelsea and the only thing i
want to know is not
the complimentary letters it's what's
upsetting the team get off your chest
tell me how i can make your day better
so that
sort of then brings out their confidence
and makes them a much better individual
and allows them to become heard um
it substantiates their voice but
clearing the air
is called clearing the problems talking
is super important
and that level of communication
sometimes is brutal
but you need to talk you need to get it
off your chest and so
yeah that's quite a refreshing moment
for me when i can see all those barriers
dissipating and that confidence rising
that for me is a sign of a great chef
and you know how hard this industry is
you you need to be on top of your game
you need to be a leader
a motivator a father figure you know
someone that stands for discipline and
someone that
you know shows confidence and that's
really important
okay everything you said is completely
on point
so strong so right and such great advice
to any human living their life
or any person trying to do a business
but how do you process
people's feelings afterwards because
that's my downfall
i literally sit there and i'm like did i
upset them did i hurt them
did i freak them out like i eviscerate
myself in like a self-loathing spiral if
i think
in order to get business done that i've
upset the cart
how do you deal with that i am literally
asking life advice
yeah that's a good question so listen
you know people's feelings are different
your feelings your temperament your
thick skin and you have that
multiple levels on a daily basis i deal
with the problem first
and then i start piecing the feelings
together if you start treading on
eggshells and you start worrying about
the feelings before identifying the
program
the problem then you're the wrong way
around so feelings are
personal and sometimes you have to get
through
to their feelings for them to understand
how big the problem is so
that's a very difficult juxtaposition to
understand how far
do you push them i do understand their
feelings
but i'm very good at bringing people
back up deal with the problem get off
your chest
understand where we're going and then
start working on the feelings don't
worry about the things to begin with
because
you'll never get to the heart of the
problem drew and you'll be there for
seven days trying to get the message
across so you and i need to spend more
time together
i know and i'm realizing it's because i
didn't have parents i'm not kidding
and parents put you in your place and i
never had that i lived a life where i
had access to everything
and no one was disciplining me ever one
man that puts me in my place
oh my goodness and you have five kids
now this is gonna sound like the
weirdest segue ever but
seeing your beautiful yummy delicious
child which is now i know why i'm on
this planet is for my daughters
is um that you are doing
the make-a-wish foundation and this is
so important to us
and our show and what are you doing
right now and how can we support it
so i um we have uh the most amazing
relationship with make a wish thanks
um do you think he looks like me i do
and he's adorable
as are you but i don't mean that in a
flirty way because you're married and i
i respect your wife and i just mean you
look lovely gordon
she loves you um make-a-wish foundation
has been
hit um awfully this year and so i've
been working with
now for over uh 12 years and so the idea
of this
is collaborating together and going back
head to head with the amazing sean evans
on the hot ones
and having a competition to see who has
the strongest palette
how many more wings can i devour how
much more can i sweat
from every hole in my body and um
raise money for make-a-wish because
listen we're very fortunate touchwood we
have five very healthy kids
um and we're blessed but make-a-wish has
suffered tremendously this year and so
the idea is to raise
you know substantial funds for them in
order to help them through this
difficult year and you've worked with
them a long time
and you've been such an important figure
for them